questi ragazzi è benvenuto che sono
video sono vari j
oggi siamo a sto cazzo di cavo primo
pelo taglierò nella vita prima o poi ad
oggi siamo il secondo episodio di
cazzeggio time è praticamente ragazzi
nell'episodio di oggi farò una cosa
pazzesca che non avete idea proprio di
che cosa sia
[Musica]
sì c'è c'era scritto anche nel titolo
per c'era scritto anche port canicola
fuga voglio fare un episodio suakin ator
ragazzi che prendete sarebbe questo
gioco per chi non lo conoscesse private
questo è un genio anche sarà la faccia
sembra più che altro un alcolizzato che
riesce a leggervi nel pensiero e riesce
indovinare personaggio al quale state
pensando è una roba pazzesca era al
bando quindi ragazzi oggi sono qui per
cercare di indovinare me stesso suakin
ator vedere se funziona la cosa ragazzi
così vedono le ultime partite fatte in
assoluto di caccia ha pensato a piccolo
aiutante che problemi c'hai per pensare
a piccolo aiutante di babbo natale un
ragazzo che scommette su tutto ma kobe
po baudo ma che cazzo state a pensare
maraga ma che cazzo pensa la gemma vince
ma cosa
mentre sto facendo il vino qualcuno ha
pensato a fa vigente perfetto ragazzi
fantastico senza dubbio fa vj ha
affiancato a johnny depp perché qua c'è
della sec saggine che trasuda animo
soggiorno che cazzo età ok e me l'ha
presa pure a ragazzi come prima cosa
penso a me stesso vediamo se riesce ad
azzeccare mi questa roba il suo
personaggio viene dall'italia si il suo
personaggio più di 26 anni con quella
bella barbetta che c'hai potrei
dimostrarli però non ce l'ho ancora la
barbetta quindi no il suo personaggio è
famoso il suo personaggio indossa
vestiti femminili
no no no no non proprio il suo
personaggio vivete nella stessa causa
seppi sul personaggio è nato il suo
stesso giorno si è nato il mio stesso
giorno grazie grazie a caso il suo
personaggio fa custom ap minecraft no mi
sono già più di 17 anni
perché se molti me ne danno 89 però se
il suo personaggio viene dal marocco
come cazzo fa sapere che sono stato in
marocco il suo personaggio parla
fluentemente francese è forse un pò di
fan separa un pochettino il suo
personaggio ha mai avuto i capelli rosa
come faccio l'aver i capelli rosa io ma
che cazzo in oman e mi stai facendo
tramite questi capelli li adoro sembra
troppo zombie che un personaggio
il suo personaggio meno di 16 anni ma se
mai chiesto se no 20 prima si con sé
personaggio è padre ma come non sono
padre e zio adesso cosa ho vent'anni
testa di casa possono già recitato in
ocean's thirteen alla madonna mi ha
preso per george clooney
no anzi non hai capito un cazzo già
fatto la sua ombra ascoltati non ho
pensato a te ok non ragazzi non ho
pensato direi proprio di no a un canale
youtube di videogiochi si dai cioè 6
azzeccando si è uno sportivo longo
plastico ragazzi non so dirvi che è
possibile se no il suo passaggio scrive
libri visto di storia è vero che i
ragazzi questa questa è storia questo è
un nome d'arte
mi chiamo fa vj dalla nascita credi e
sardo di persona già che fare con fa vj
ha indovinato in una domanda ragazzi ma
si può
no no la sorella sono figlio unico ma
che cazzo te ne frega zio indovina a che
fare con fame lei già chiesto a vicenza
dodici ore per indovinata cagata c dio
mio che bella foto tranche sec sito
veramente or gassman i ragazzi siccome
ho capito che a me indovina passiamo ad
un altro personaggio andiamo su giocala
e proviamo un altro giusto per capire io
ho 2015 anni sono nato nell'anno zero
come gesù cristo che è in te lo dico
così a me non lo sai non vi dico a chi
sto pensando voglio provare a vedere se
noi indovinata anche voi non è un canale
di youtube grazie a dio
aggiungerei pure reale non è reale
grazie a dio anche questo è il suo
personaggio ai capelli non solo
indovinate voi minchia applausi ragazzi
applauso da parte di un videogioco si fa
parte del genere horror no cammina su
due gambe dagli vinciamo i 16 amici ma
anche se sono zampe fichera è un animale
se è bianco mi piacciono passo perché
bianca non ci credo è un gatto ragazzi
ve l'ha preso lega non ci credo sia un
gatto ma come cazzo ha fatto il suo
personaggio parlano e muto grazie a dio
anche questo me l'ha indovinata
se mi ha indovinato che mario come ha
fatto indovinare micat mario videogame
coreano cazzo fate indovina mi chiamare
un altro personaggio di videogiochi
dalla prova di che cazzo successi su
personaggi di ragazzi e un altro
personaggio di videogames stavolta è
diverso da chi mario provate a
indovinare anche questo saraceni
nazionalità italiana direi proprio di no
e veramente esistito spero di no perchè
se no non esco pd caso fa parte di un
cartone
no è cattivo abbastanza fa parte del
videogioco file night at freddi come ha
fatto a indovinare freddi come il cazzo
ha fatto di dominare freddo ci voglio
mai credere non ci voglio mai credere la
festa è un'altra roba tipo un po più
difficile
il padre di uk però il padre il padre di
uk in indovina bile il padre di uk e
voglio vedere che cazzo tira fuori viene
dall italiano windows abiti maschili si
ma esiste davvero no ai baffi
se ai baffi non lo sapevo ha più di un
figlio no grazie a dio e senza gambe a
volte senza gambe ma di partenza no a
che fare con la china e tornò a che fare
con fa vj ma perché è fa con indosso un
elmo un casco si è un padre non ci credo
non ci sto credendo non ci sto credendo
mai come cazzo ha fatto non è possibile
non lo sciacca ragazzi indovinano non sa
che me ne va giuro che me ne vado in
giro in mutande non è possibile che fare
con fa vigeva perché mi chiede sempre
sta cosa di fa vj ma che cazzo vuole la
famiglia e manici in ora non ho già ma
cosa come ha fatto indovinarli nonno
chive ma chi è che ha cercato nonno chat
su 1.300 va bene va a fan culo
l'ultima cosa che voglio provare a fare
inventare un personaggio completamente a
casa da provava immaginarci na roba col
bel collo è bello lo chiamerò beat beat
scritto pitt perfetta viene dall'italia
è un ex pornoattore è maschio si indossa
le scarpe no non c'è i piedi compare
nella bibbia ragazzi siamo forse pitt ha
fatto qualche miracolo che io sappia no
ma le gambe certo che ce l'hai già anche
belle grosse ha prodotto un brano che of
dogs
[Musica]
marzo no ma direi di no hai fatto
qualche canzone insieme a parte l'inter
a firma però cielo il candidato pensando
a niente se veramente uguale cazzo non
sto vedendo la differenza ragazze che
ragazzi concluso che l'episodio volevo
provare un po giocare su ha chinato e mi
ami mi stupisce che pensi così tanto ha
messo stronzo c'è una cosa un po strana
prova per i ragazzi concluso qui questo
episodio di cazzeggio time l'ho fatto
più che altro perché era un po diverso
dai videogiochi che faccio di solito
visto che non è proprio un gioco e
niente la cava era da un pezzo che
volevo fare sta roba quindi sono
contento di averla fatta perché è
veramente strano come funzioni sta roba
cioè comunque a parte gli scherzi
ragazzi spero che ha visto vi sia
piaciuto per ogni mi piace che mettete
un taglio di mafia e di barba per che
cazzo non si può vedere sta roba
cosa i ragazzi se vi è piaciuto al
sottovento mi piace ai capace di
facebook che come noi video tolga una
descrizione sono sempre su discreti di
civili diavolo prossimo ai ragazzi